supongamos que nos han dado esta
información acerca de la función g y sus
derivadas evaluadas en dos sabemos qué g
de 2 es igual a 3 g prima de 2 es igual
a 1 la segunda derivada de gen 2 es
igual a menos 1 la tercera derivada de
gen 2 es igual a 2 dada esa información
el reto que se nos plantea es usar un
polinomio de taylor de segundo grado
centrado en x igualados centrado en x
igual a 2 para aproximar g prima de 11 g
de 1g prima de 1 por lo pronto te invito
a que le pongas pausa al vídeo e
intentes resolverlo por tu cuenta
supongo que ya lo intentaste ahora
hagámoslo juntos para empezar recordemos
cómo se ve un polinomio de taylor de
segundo grado de cualquier función f en
general centrado en x igual a 2
tenemos que fx es aproximadamente igual
efe 2
más
efe prima de 2 que multiplica a x menos
2 más
efe mi prima de 2 que multiplica a x2
elevado al cuadrado dividido entre 2
factorial esto nos da un polinomio de
segundo orden pues x menos 2 al cuadrado
nos da un polinomio de segundo grado
ahora esta es la forma general para
aproximar fx centrada en x igualados
pero nosotros queremos la forma del
polinomio para encontrar que prima de 1
déjame escribir esto lo voy a hacer en
azul
así es que queremos la forma de la
aproximación de g prima de x para
posteriormente evaluarla cuando x es
igual a 1 entonces que prima de x es
aproximadamente igual a es lo mismo que
hicimos arriba es la función que quiero
aproximar evaluada en 2 en este caso que
prima de 2 observa que si estoy
aproximando fx es esa función de valor
en dos si esté aproximando que prima de
x es esa función evaluar en 2
más la primera derivada de la función
evaluada en 2 que en este caso es heavy
prima evaluada en 2 que multiplica a x
menos 2 más
la segunda derivada de la función
evaluada en 2 que en este caso la
segunda derivada de ge prima es la
tercera derivada de g
así es que la tercera derivada de g
evaluada en 2 que multiplica a x 2
elevado al cuadrado y todo eso sobre 2
factorial y estos valores no nos dan
estos valores no los han dado aquí voy a
usar nuevos colores nos han dado g de 2
igual a 3 g de 21 g de 2 no lo
necesitamos necesitamos que prima de 2 g
de dos no lo usamos que prima de 2 es
igual a uno que prima de 2 es igual a 1
así es que este es igual a 1 heavy prima
de 2 es igual a menos 1 este de aquí es
menos 1 y la tercera derivada de g
evaluada en 2
así es que aquí tenemos que esto vale 2
sobre 2 factorial los factoriales 2 por
1 es igual a 2 así es que estos dos se
cancelan y entonces que nos queda de
esta aproximación que nos queda de esta
aproximación de segundo grado de g prima
de x centrada en x igualados nos queda
que que prima de x que prima de x es
igual que prima de x es aproximadamente
igual a 1
- x 2 x 2 que puede escribir
directamente como 2 x 1 +
2 - x menos x menos 2 es lo mismo que 2
- x y eso más
x2 elevado al cuadrado aquí puedo sumar
12 para obtener entonces que esto es
igual a 3 x más x menos 2 elevado al
cuadrado y ahora ya podemos evaluar si
queremos evaluar g prima de uno que
prima de uno es aproximadamente igual
donde aparece x voy a sustituir uno esto
es tres menos uno más uno menos dos
elevado al cuadrado
3 - 1 es 21 menos dos es menos uno
elevado al cuadrado es uno menos uno
elevado al cuadrado es 1 así es que nos
queda 2 más 1
esto es igual a 3 3 es el valor que
hemos obtenido como la aproximación de g
prima de 1 que hicimos encontramos la
aproximación de taylor la aproximación
del polinomio de taylor de segundo grado
centrada en x igualados paraje prima de
x y después evaluamos eso cuando x es
igual a 1 para obtener así
aproximación de eje prima de uno en fin
espero que te hayas divertido